[Music]
welcome thanks for joining me for this
session had to decolonize your mind I am
professor Kylie Andrews purser of Black
Studies at Birmingham City University
and the idea about the colonizing is
important because if you've been
involved in the festival hopefully
you've been involved in some of the
discussions around just how unequal
society is and the need to decolonize
society more broadly it's probably one
of the most urgent and pressing needs of
the 21st century and that process starts
with starts at home
it starts with changing the way in which
we think about the basic premises of
society so the colonized mind is born
because one sweetie Carla is the mind
hopefully then we start to see the world
differently and to act differently a
society can only be as equal as a
knowledge which is on and unfortunately
or unsurprisingly the knowledge that
base the knowledge and myths the conduct
in this society are incredibly unequal
illusional and extorted so it is
therefore it's essential as any process
of change that we undo that undo the lie
that we've been told about how we got to
where we are and where we are going so
over the next half an hour a little bit
less enough now I am going to kind of
give her a path a path to a different
way of understanding things which
hopefully will be uncomfortable which
hopefully will shake some of the
foundations and if not maybe you know
some of this stuff will be allow you
give you a blueprint to sharing it more
broadly as well all right so how to
decolonize your mind first things first
really it is about understanding the
nature of the problem and the nature of
this particular problem is the life it's
big lies that we've been sold to the
myths to underpin how we understand the
world and it is these it is these lies
and these myths which continue to mean
that we can only understand the world in
very distorted and problematic ways so
in order to colonize your mind the first
thing to do is to destabilize these
myths to debunk them
absolutely essential so the first part
of doing that is understanding what the
lie is so one of the the way these kind
of lies were kind of kind of try to put
it in this level because it does revolve
around the idea of revolution and where
we end up this a number of times
actually is this over this weekend with
the in the debate this progress
narrative you know the West is all about
progress and it's about these massive
revolutions in science politics in
industry we are led to believe that the
three pillars of the west side the
Scientific Revolution the political
ability and the Industrial Revolution
and is those things which have made
progress and even as the technology
where we are today that's not 100%
untrue right we had science changing
moving away from religious explanations
and rationality and maths physics we
learned that you really couldn't have
the table or the technology that were
literally sitting on we're doing this we
would be would be impossible without
science so there is truth some truth in
the idea that Western science has been
really important in terms of development
the same true is true with industry
right industry the Industrial Revolution
in the 18th century onwards is seen to
be one of the big moments of change
where the science that's the science and
rationality was put to use simple to
work changed how things were produced
allowed there to be plenty you think
about what's the big difference now is
that we just have so much stuff so much
material well and that was produced by
the Industrial Revolution which started
you know Britain Europe and expanded out
to the world so again is this truth and
in the third part of this this myth is
the political revolutions so moving away
from monarchies and being covered by
heredity and having democracy etc etc
and is being really important because it
gives us the frames of Rights and those
frames of rights and the individual
etcetera etcetera cetera and these are
the three things just seem to embed
embedded underlie the West and these are
the three things which was the West is
supposed to give into the world and if
only everybody else could just catch up
with finance industry politics wouldn't
the world be a better place no I saying
that's all party true because it is part
it is partly true there is some truth to
that but there is a another side to this
none of these things scientific
revolution industrial pollution or
political revolution could have happened
without some of the worst atrocities
ever committed by a human kind there is
a there is a dark side to modernity
which is just as important as the
wonderfully good progressed professed
values but the West is supposed to be
built up with one of the first things
you want to think about when the
colonized in the mind is to shift the
idea from these these so-called good
West so-called Western and so-called
good values or British values that we
say in the UK and to understand that
genocide slavery colonialism are equally
as important if not more important than
the
[Music]
better than the good sides of Western
development
so we're thinking about ID colonizing
the minus of money if you have heard me
talk before you definitely would have
heavy use Malcolm X references and
Malcolm talks about the change which
happens I will hear a different telling
of history as like snow falling offer
mr. Malcolm when he heard about races
and at the bottom the West Point his
life and he's reading and learning stuff
and he's just completely in that process
of learning was like snow falling off it
truly transformed from into a statesman
and so this is hopefully what can happen
through the process of the colonizing
your mind that we to have your eyes open
and to see the world anew so that's why
it's really important to stabilize those
three myths about how great the West is
an air great things are today so I'm
gonna go we're gonna go back do this we
have to go back and tell a different
story
about the West story again some of you
may be well aware of it some of you may
not but this is a really important
history so before we go back and as you
know this is going back edge this is
going back to one of our really
important scientists so when we think
about science and we think about
scientific revolution we think about
rationality
classification one of the supposed
benefits of science of religion is the
idea that you see the world through
object through objective lens you see
the world through rationality you don't
have the same kind of subjective
oppressive view right unfortunately no
so you would think that would be the
case and the shift from religious
explanations to scientific explanations
should in this logic mean that there is
a more equal understanding of the human
world it was exactly the opposite shift
from religious explanations of humanity
and he prior to the Enlightenment into
science it was all about who had a soul
you could have a soul who Africans have
souls the Native Americans also best so
who who has sold understanding
difference from scientific rationality
we can who has royality who has the
right genes who has right genetic code
and this is from cruelty Lincoln is one
of the really important botanists in the
18th century
he still today actually really important
in terms of how human classification
classification for the species is used
basically classifies at the human
species and very clearly classifiers in
this way so says at the top of the human
species there is europaeus
helpers who is ingenious white sanguine
governed by law as the top of the
Imperial pyramid then you have America's
REE whiskers happy with his lot
liberty-loving tan and irascible and
governed by custom yeah the glow after
America's for biscuits you then have AGA
larita's you know melancholy and
governed by opinion until finally you
get to the bottom of the human pyramid
and you have ever lied you crafty lazy
black governed by the arbitrary will of
the master and you can see them through
scientific classification in the late
18th century of humanity now I picked at
renée's because it's so clear and it's
so color coded white great yellow back
to show the hierarchy humanity but he's
certainly not alone Immanuel Kant
Voltaire Rousseau I mean all the basic
rule the Enlightenment thinkers read any
and they had a similar sometimes the
that order differed in between but why
are the top black at the bottom all of
them classified human species that he
must be into a different species often
certainly different people expelling a
hierarchy of white supremacy at the top
the idea of being here that only white
people can be pink only what can be
rational and Africans are far closer to
you to animals but actually know if I'm
closer to animals and many of these are
actually just enemy this is what becomes
cousin up to dating this you know about
the human rights element the rationality
element all these positive things have
come from enlightenment however I can't
separate them from the ratio science of
the Enlightenment because someone like
Ken for example he was really important
in telling rights and actually lays the
framework for human rights that we had
today makes it very clearly his work on
race which is just classic racism as we
work on rights cannot be separated only
Europeans only white who have the
ability to be fully rational and to some
extent you should give rights to
everybody in the world but they should
not be the same right so the right to
life which is embedded in the human
rights framework is the basic in animals
have the right to life is it not give
you the right to fulfilment and humanity
and then write a humanity has never been
granted to those who are black this is a
really important point to make right no
it's a philosophical point it's not just
a discussion about well you know are
there different ways that we can
conceive conceive of the human etc so
this actually is what global inequality
looks like today to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit a I dot TV for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas